So we talked about the GitHub workflow
how you branch, introduce changes on
commits, and then merge your branch back
into master but that only works if
you're working on a project that you
have a write access to. Maybe you're
working on a project that you don't have
collaborator access to, like if I wanted
to make changes on Free Code Camp. That's
when you would need the open-source
workflow which includes forking. When you
create a fork on github.com you're
creating a copy of that repository but
under your own account so you have write
access. So let's say I fork Free Code
Camp's repository, now I have write access
to it, I can make commits directly to
that repository but they can't see them
on Free Code Camp yet -
that's ok - once I create my own fork then
I make commits on my for kind of make
the changes that I think you know Free
Code Camp should include and then I can
open a pull request from my fork
directly to free code camps fork the
process is overall a little bit similar
to the branching process because it
includes another copy of the code making
commits in a safe place and then
introducing them with a pull request but
the main difference is the ownership of
the separate repositories the original
fork would be under Free Code Camp my
for could be under my name. When we
aren't using the branching process
everything is still a part of that same
repository. So just to review, this fork
and pull workflow is really helpful in
open-source. It includes creating a fork
of the repository, making commits there,
and then opening a pull request against
the original fork.